hello everybody happy Friday
hello how how's it going how's it going
how's it going uh I'm doing well
we're here doing some sweet monster
hunts today monster hunts with you the
community because today is a special day
oh yeah it is we've got hot crossover
content do that that reprints he's just
dancing having a good time jazz hands so
they they finally put in the first like
crossover costume thing for your
characters I'm not counting the the
horizon zero dawn
cat though the end apparently the end of
the month is when we get we get yeah but
for now we've got Ryu he's looking good
it's like he just straight-up ripped the
model out of the game and all he looks
wonderful
put it on your character and that is
five for you yeah yeah so we're gonna be
doing that quest showing you what it's
what it's all about we're gonna be
checking out the new event quests
there's one we've got to fight five
monsters in 50 minutes it's gonna be a
heck of an experience this can be real
good and as always if you would like to
join in on our lobby and take part in
our hunt we've got right here here down
down here a code a code for you to join
in
so please we're on ps4 I'm gonna stop
talking because I feel like I've not let
you say anything I know that's fine but
yeah so we're gonna we're gonna yeah so
we're gonna we're gonna show off what
this quest is like apparently I have to
it seven times yeah so I don't think
we're gonna do that which is why I kind
of went ahead last night and I actually
got me an outfit so I can use it and
other hunts so we can still see it but
we don't have to make you guys watch us
fight just fight it seven times that's a
bit much a real real good bear off
multiple times but yeah so down the dark
muddy path is what we're looking forward
to it's a level three it's not too hard
but maybe a little it it's more
difficult than I thought it would okay
you'll find out why as soon as we get in
alright which is gonna be a it's gonna
be a fun thing it's a bit of a spectacle
actually cool uh don't give me some food
all you don't even need food because
it's an arena quest right wasted my food
it's okay I got you
I called too called it out thank you
let's do some honestly we're on the way
Ellen no we are doing it make it happen
yeah so this is the quest for getting
the Ryu armor and show it to you guys
it's gonna be a good time I'm ready for
departure step that five months Rose is
easy to be honest finishing our 20
minutes if it reverses by shoot oh it
just makes me look like Ryu so you in
the quest hold on to your butts it's
gonna get wild so I don't know how to
use like any of these weapons I don't
use dual blade so I'm gonna stick with
that yeah I kind of like in the process
of doing this quest last night sort of
learned how to use a hammer so I think I
like about arena quest yeah
so also if if you're watching me and
you're like man this hammer guy's really
bad please just give me hints teach me
because I don't want them doing someone
said that five monster quest is rather
easy yeah they're able to finish in
under 20 if the wrath was I doesn't fly
away I thought it took 15 oh no it's
it's a 50-minute quest 50 minute yeah
yeah right alright so you see this right
now there we go we got some some extra
to image uh what do you notice it's kind
of weird about this bear off he's a lot
bigger
he's very large it's a real real big
dude they just took that character model
and and scaled it up yes they did a 50%
there all right so that that also means
like he's actually like bigger watching
Ryu do the ninja run with the dual
blades it's a plus highlight of my day
right now uh yeah so this his hitbox for
everything is bigger he actually like oh
it's playing the street fighter yeah it
gets real good this is good this is good
hashtag video games
I shouldn't have gone into that oh also
his mud piles are bingo Frank West
crossover and should monster on her they
really should know the state of dead
rising is maybe less than desirable yes
but but Frank West and just monster and
I'd be pretty into that my personal
thing is just put Frank in everything
because yeah he's pretty good she's the
best character she gotta put you gotta
put in original Frank yes definitely
none of that for nonsense did I actually
I mean it makes sense after playing
reuse theme but what if they put an
indestructible from Street Fighter or
I feel like they want to just bury that
slung and now but they shouldn't he
shouldn't along with the original
Dragon's Dogma theme never oh it's good
it's real good
I'm excited now you should you should
definitely check check that one out if
you haven't they took it out for all of
the releases some reason but see we're
getting a couple of questions here and
chat let's see someone's ask if you can
throw a Hadouken
yes actually I should do that because I
have it all lined up it's it's a premium
emote and I'm gonna tell you right now
these emotes costs like four or five
dollars a piece
oh you have to actually spend money on
them you actually actually spend money
on I also got the the pictures because
they're only two dollars I'm like why
not I don't know if I'll do that it's
not here someone's wondering if the
large bear off counts towards a golden
crown counts oh there we go found it um
I don't think so
it definitely counts as your record for
your largest one okay so you actually
throw headings is actually done all come
on oh I'm stunned it's okay I got you
got me oh you did the Hadouken I saw it
though he's real angry at me now for it
yeah just a gross do a shoryuken yeah
damn just a little bit of a bad I'm
gonna knock his tail off just by
uppercutting him there we go there we go
there we go there we go
I main emotes in Street Fighter in
Monster Hunter Alan wants to know if
monster is worth buying absolutely yes
highly recommend I hit a hundred and
sixty hours ago out of hours that was a
hundred more hours and I have and I
don't want to stop playing well I'm
actually like 80 or hours I think let's
not count there we go alright so no I
know that with hammer the best thing is
mashing out circle like you do one of
these and you yeah I know that's that's
the the real the real business there are
a lot of moves in this game that are
just like you're gonna hit the button
and the animation is gonna play out and
you pray to God the monster doesn't move
yep yep that's great sword like a
hundred percent which is I tried using
it and I don't it's been a very long
time since I've used great sword and I
was having a real real rough time yeah a
lot of dual blade it's got this one move
that where you just stand there and and
just spin for like 30 seconds but
hit-boy if you miss that you're gonna
it's awkward the best part of the hammer
exactly you're just kind of like wail on
it it's great hello NH how you doing
happy Friday everyone
yeah so who's who's excited it's just to
have a weekend and play more Monster
Hunter cuz that's I know that's Ryan at
this point I'm mainly keeping up with it
through this dream that's fair I've been
been moving on to other games I need to
shoot your uh dance round with them for
a little bit I need to sharpen my hammer
can do oh yeah to do this quest this
week you need to have Street Fighter 5
save data yes if you so you can unlock
it if you don't you just have to UM you
get like a week later or something right
yeah well here we go one more time I'm
gonna do it on his face though cuz
that's the true you're supposed to do it
I'm primarily a blade person so I'm
always on the tail
but like I messed it up I messed it up
I'll never be a real hammer bro so
instead of the secret man every man came
out yesterday Wow
Yeah right a man who that kind of snuck
up on me then I don't even know that
right
the big thing is today Bayonetta bayonet
on the switch is out in fact we are
gonna be doing a livestream meet and
been yeah you could double dose double
dose pending John Luke I'm real sorry
guys but here we are
it'll be a good time though I promise
yes we're gonna play some Bayonetta talk
about cool things how bayonet is the
best holiday game for you to play Spain
Christmas Iannetta to does man that's
whether they're all shopping around at
the beginning I made the recent
revelation that the majority of Yakuza
games take place during Christmas yeah
like 0 1 2 & 5
I for sure and I think 6 does as well I
believe so yes well maybe what is the
the best holiday game to play man maybe
Yakuza maybe maybe but bayonet is really
good too though it's like a shame black
situation
there's everyone's a winner hmm oh
there's so many holiday Christmassy
themed games
Saints Row 3 had that you'll see me
actually that I do actually really like
that Saints Row 3 DLC it's a good DLC 3
or 4 it might have been for my before
actually but I remember laughing at that
quite a bit a lot of a lot of good
reference a lot of good references what
even is a hammer hit box we did it that
was actually a lot easier than last time
all right cool so like you said we have
to do that seven times seven times okay
so we're not gonna do that again that's
just gonna be boring to watch yeah but
it's okay you know you've seen what it
is you've seen us as we use murdering
mobsters we're just pretty good and
you're gonna stick with Yuri you see and
I think y'all
carve ok so there's there's no real
carbs an arena or potions got it okay
which is nice I guess but yeah yeah we
got a b2 so we got two tickets whoa
cuz we did we got a B ranks I mean if
you get a you get three oh I wouldn't
know cuz solo playing I only got C's
okay so it won't take as long then yeah
if you're good get that F ADC alright so
now I think we're just gonna move on to
the event quest for the week yeah I'm
excited
hey goob how's it going Gibson the chat
what's up man oh I got my login bonus oh
yeah sweet vouchers oh yeah I gotta use
some batteries I got too many oh yeah
you leave them to kind of stack up and
you're just yeah but they stack up to
five at least which is nice we got pals
in the in the room now hehe we got some
people in here that's great if you if
you want to join us please do yeah we
got a got a couple people in here let's
gets into those Street Fighter pose and
everything do it oh that's good oh
that's excellent I like this this is
pretty good all right let's see here
what are we gonna do next what is your
favorite DLC okay couple times that's
actually thinking about that for
whatever reason on the walk
I heard of work feel like the default
answer is red Dead's
undead nightmare DLC really guys it's
really good
I love lair the shadow broker from
aspect - it's real good - along with
Citadel for mass spec 3 so that was like
a good time a whole basis for a cool
series you did yeah me and Jake the
entire premise being to get to that
party in the Citadel it's a good time it
was very fun
go and check that out yeah means you we
played through Mass Effect 2 & 3 with
the purposes of trying to kill every
squad member if that's possible to kill
yeah yeah and we did it it was a heck of
a ride real funny
so what we got here is Tsar Magna ropes
yeah newt another chew the fat one with
two jaggers's and then so you just get
sore Magnus out of the way do this arm a
gross one it's kind of weird that's good
that optimum farming path down yeah do
it up I think I probably need them for
like a blade or something so I'm okay
doing it oh right
join you know what I'm gonna use a
voucher Dom again more people in perfect
this this is my favorite part of the
show when people start to like doing the
session excellent I like I like that a
lot we go for two more we actually can
eat for this one because it's not an
arena quests mm-hmm oh man
Ryu what are you doing oh it's a long
way away from home squad invite oh we
can we can do that I think I think you
have to do the invite though when you
get yeah anyone who's in the session I
can go ahead and and invite them we'll
just send out a mass invite quad oh this
is pretty sick same your aunt sweet seat
there this is what I like
all these always cool people hanging out
way too squad here we go so just hit
everyone you're already in I'm gonna
fighting you I'm inviting you I'm
inviting you get an invite you get an
invite all right if you're in the
session you'll get an invite to the
Monster Hunter Mondays just now on
Fridays I can't change the name but
we're just that's fine yeah that's
that's okay we've got that sweet squad
SEO Monster Hunter Mondays forever
monster honor Mondays on a Fridays cool
ready to go I'm set stoked let's do this
I literally have gotten to the point
where I just ignore this quest though
yeah I mean me too these I'm not that
much reason to uh to do it
Oh Wolverine in Monster Hunter Oh what
is our dream Monster Hunter crossover
what is the the app the optimum best
crazy over-the-top
thing ever I would say metal gear but
it's already happened and metal gear
it's them and that they did the metal
gear one real real good real real well
real real hard to talk this early in the
morning it's kind of tough to do cuz
like trying to get like an iconic armor
but like some uh some Dark Souls
crossover I feel like would that would
make sense make a lot of sense
yeah I don't know like which army you
pick like an art aureus armor set or
something maybe what if they just put a
to be skin in the game and then had a
whole bunch of specials from oh man yeah
they should definitely do it to be that
crossover can he Tatsu he can't game vet
I'm sorry they did it to be crossover in
what's it called not Soul Calibur but I
think that the best Jess character oh
yeah they did
it's the only way to play gravity rush -
did you think the new Soul Calibur it's
gotta have ridiculous guest characters
it has to have guests that's like third
they're like gimmick at this point I
think I'm weather I wonder if they're
trying to get away from that as a
gimmick though the whole premise of this
this Soul Calibur it's like a reboot
kind of like from a story perspective
weird yeah it's it's a weird situation
for sure but I still think to be would
be a great choice for a guest character
in Soul Calibur now I agree at bat let's
hit it
go beat up that giant not Godzilla
monster Ryu source is Dante didn't hop
in Yeah right
that would actually be good because
they're doing the they're doing that HD
collection in like a month or two get
that sweet cross-promotions so like a
cross-promote with that with that HD
collection out I'm excited for that
same I've been saying that I want to
play through those games again but I
don't want to pull out my old collection
it's like oh you gotta pull up the ps3
you know or whatever or a ps2 if you
really want to play it real authentic
with it
get real off that thing there we go
perfect all according to plan
grab that fragment make her way up it's
kind of something I whenever I do this
history OHS I always try and find the
original version yeah because I'm
talking about it someone was actually
giving me crap from whoa in the Yakuza
one they're like why didn't you just use
kiwami footage when you were talking
about yaku's at one I was like because
they're like a different game at that
point like yeah oh I'm gonna get hit by
that no matter where I go try and keep
it authentic who says how do you do a
Hadouken in this game you spend money
you have to pay money for it I buy money
for a Hadouken which is a little low
Lane yeah
and it's it's not like the same price as
the other ones it's it's a more more
premium price point but I mean if you
really really want it it's there for you
all right then we jump off fragments
over this way I'm not gonna get that
other mining thing I'm just just gonna
just gonna feel this out I'm gonna go
the way that I remember maybe we can try
to kick some says Gerald I assume you
mean Carol Oh Gerald from Gerald from
the witcher's my finger because they say
he's also monster unless there's a
monster hunter a guy who hunts monsters
named gerald which would be pretty good
it would be very good but this isn't it
this isn't what I'm looking for these
are just the pictures I'm trying to pull
back out my my Hadouken and sure you can
again I don't remember where I have put
them should probably characters no but
that'd be really good I'd be pretty good
just like a Chris
well there it is I found it it's in it's
in communication because the only way to
communicate is with hadoukens this is
content I am real stoked that monster
hunter is is doing really well I keep
saying if you like it
yeah I'm really excited to play it on PC
again I'm just real stoked people are
playing Monster Hunter where's the
Megaman DLC yet wasn't he a palico he
was a palco at one point but now I think
the DLC is be another palco outfit and
we also get special weapons
oh so they've like they're expanding
upon that yes it's not available yet
though no but the cool thing about the
weapons is that from what I hear they
changed music that plays while you fight
and I'm very excited because the
longsword song is just Wiley's castle so
that's gonna be a real good time did you
got a still show up in this I think so
oh why is your arm on fire yeah exactly
like Talan saying it's kind of to show
that you have something loaded up in
your your launcher oh I guess have one I
guess where you just use it as what oh
no that's never happened in this Reeves
dead guy I can't believe this what is
even happening how did we get here now
we're gonna miss out on some of those
sweets or rewards never died on Sora
Magna Rose ever
I'm never picking this rear skin again
this I'm done it's bad luck Dragon Ball
Z in Monster Hunter Oh Goku monster just
Kamehameha like a Rathalos into
non-existence
that'd be pretty good I'm gonna pretend
that I know a lot about Dragon Ball I'm
pretty much a master now because I
played fighter Z right
oh definitely you know all about yeah
the the freezes and your yourselves
exactly was it you could probably tell
me the entire plot Dragonball there's a
point work a guy gets angry and they end
up fighting each other for six episodes
give myself any of these deals he's our
console exclusive The Horizon ones the
only one that's console exclusive they
all are timed though is the thing so you
kind of do miss out on it if you don't
have the game already yeah which is sort
of the big thing I was kind of all
though I imagine on the PC they'll find
a way to like resurface yeah this stuff
right or people will have mods and you
can be whatever character you want
exactly I can be any Street Fighter
character that's that's what we need
that's that content we really need all
right so let's fight who we're actually
here to fight yeah I shouldn't judge
drinks is a Lurie skin is the best
choice I I think aesthetically makes the
perfect sense it really does so maybe I
should get some some nutrients inside of
me
thanks for the invite anytime happy to
have you oh yeah absolutely
Oh Ryu is here to help me out something
about the long path ahead the the wrote
battles are hard I will continue
fighting until my fists turn into dust I
don't remember any good Ryu coats
freaking out when I saw you is Ryu right
it's real it's kind of jarring actually
like you see all these really cool like
armor sets and you see like a really
beefy dude running around in like a
karate guy where the Sakura skin arm as
a male character yes yeah you can play
any armor regardless of gender which is
great because you don't want to get left
out on some of the content you know so
it'll actually change your your voice
it'll change how you look it's a real a
real good time overall I'm gonna try to
don't try to beat up his nose
if I can make it up here I'll punch you
in the face hard is a choice Rico yeah
I'm sitting there thinking about that
Dante stuff so they had Dante crossover
stuff in master hundred before okay
where you could dress your pallet go up
like Dante and give him rebellion as a
weapon that's pretty good I think that
was for ultimate maybe possibly move
your head back over here sir are you
doing bring it back huh oh shoot oh god
no oh no what's a good thing my my
pterodactyl friends are here oh you guys
are still fighting on yeah he's already
get rid of for whatever reason oh no let
me just jump off again that's exactly
what I needed to do
why is he facing backwards
never seen that happen uh I think Zora
macarons just like turned his head like
180 degrees I'm trying to shoot fire at
me maybe losing my mind
can't wait for the PC version using your
keyboards 109 instead of having to
scroll through the items oh my goodness
oh that's the dream especially if I can
it like lets you like use both at the
same time so primarily play with
controller but then just like hit now
just hit my keyboard oh that's real good
that would be the ideal situation from
here some fragments Oh a ton of frag
there we go oh man look at all these
fragments I might be a little late yep
that's fine that's okay
yep and give me that fragment oh that
was great
it's continuing its advance
oh no we were talking about it last
night we're doing her a metal gear thing
a monster that I don't want to ever see
come back is definitely the the like
Monster Hunter version of Metal Gear Rex
I I was thinking about it more last
night and it's probably the scariest
looking thing I've seen oh and it's just
really gross oh one punch punch man
crossovers would be interesting
oh you'd pay $15 for an emote with just
one shots everything I'd buy it yeah
more anime but bring in the anime give
it to me now I think I can actually your
hold on since standstill for a second
I like knock me down I don't I don't
want to knock it down oh no it doesn't
oh it does does nice okay so they're
they're good emotes to troll with too
which is great can you yep you totally
hit me Wow oh can we can have cool cool
little fights
somebody said one piece mister dreadful
that'd be good - I kind of liked I'd be
a skeleton boy I feel like I'd really
like one piece but I'm too afraid to
jump into it because there's so many
episodes name I feel bad that I'm just
punching you now okay we just got a kill
time until high this part of them this
quest is pretty whatever yeah and it's
gonna stand up again it's worth farming
for the for the skins and armor or when
weapons to get but after that boy I got
you oh yes you lived
I almost got your red eyes I almost got
you alright so this is the fun part
where you just kind of run around and
load up cannons just shoot the boy shoot
the boy as he walks over towards you
also it's kind of cool seeing ryu with
all these like silly Monster Hunter
animations yeah that's pretty good like
it get the time to tune all right we're
gonna turn this a little bit that's too
far
REE what are you doing you know what
we'll just leave it there that's fine
shoot it yeah all right I'm gonna go run
to a different one really cool sorry
it's my first time doing those four
people same actually I've done a lot
solo oh yeah that that much I know for
sure right after this one it'll be good
to shoot yeah man a Pacific Rim thing
you try to drift in that guide you
together alright I think that's a good
spot
punch it firing
oh we broke broke his parts get got
personal load this one up all by myself
have my own thing everyone dudes heading
down for the ship the peace walker max
for crossover with monster honor I would
like to see metal gear do another
crossover you know what that that's my
answer my dream my dream crossover is
more more Metal Gear I just don't want
to see the monster version of Metal Gear
Rex ever again I think this is good all
they saw a parody episode of one one
piece and it ruined it for you oh no
there isn't there was a pretty good
parity breach series oh really
called nuttin peace oh where Luffy just
talks like Sean Connery it was pretty it
was pretty funny I said that sounds like
something that I'd be I'd be kind of
into but it was just meant to be more
like absurdist humor okay alright so all
the old cannonballs are gone he's just
like I'm 48 years old he's just like
talking like that the whole time
could you imagine I'm gonna steal this
from Futaba in the chat persona
crossover with monster hunter oh let's
get some some real cool glasses get some
people's jumped off the edge for some
reason you know sometimes you gotta you
gotta just jump off oh we already hit
the dragon eater and everything that's
why the themes playing okay I got it
sweet this is good pretty good I feel
like you could really just cross over
with anything and you'd be good
well God weird seeing real with the
sword that would have been oh yeah if
they put Vega and it would make more
sense give them like an actual like the
claws oh yeah you got this is a Sly
Cooper it's like it would be pretty rad
just put in a crash bandicoot oh heck
yeah do sign me up
Oh Oh buzz Oh Jack daxter's your pal
okay done I figure damn you've made the
ultimate crossover how did how did we
miss it there's a whole time hey Bob how
are you doing how was your Friday going
xbox only banjo kazooie I would switch
over in a heartbeat I would I would drop
my 160 our save to be
banjo in monster honor oh my god a
katamari you just dress up with the
prince and you roll up all the monsters
on the theme would play whenever you get
into a fight I'd be very into that are
you very good
we're limit to the crossover ideas are
open to anything so that's the thing is
they get all the Capcom stuff in yeah
and then they usually make deals with
the kind of related to the platform so
you know they've had like a Nintendo
stuff in the past like Samus armor
that's been pretty cool they've done a
lot of stuff with you know a LOI here
and stuff like that so I feel like it's
pretty open to just kind of your
imagination at that point yeah for uh
for Xbox I want to see a Gears of War
crossover where I can have a Lancer as a
weapon or just chainsaw all the monsters
and have a goatee that's what I want I
mean I know you're saying that and
you're in your mocking voice but I
totally buy into it I'd buy that it's
not as it's not like I would drop my
hundred sixty hours save like a banjo
thing
but I'd be into it definitely check it
out
heck yeah uh just put in the car from
Fort so horizon we've done it that's I
know I said that we've figured out the
optimum crossover but I feel like that's
actually it right there just put all the
cars from fours in and you have to fight
an actual like like a Toyota Camry in an
arena and get all the car parts off of
them Doughboy says do you guys throw
into the chat yes we do and you can sir
your previous question
this is Monster Hunter yeah I'm gonna
shoot this cannon that's only loaded up
with one shot there we go we did it sell
the DLC for switch to obvious I'm Alvin
so but if we get anything on the switch
it'll probably be a port of double-cross
which oh my god please give it to me
that's what I want more than a lot of
things because I think that one has the
highest monster Count II of any monster
honor possibly okay cool
not we did that one oh that two times
voucher bonus peasy feeling it what did
you use your voucher I did I didn't even
show up I get any cards the heck is this
it's sure they're like we watched the
chat and it does take a little while to
respond but that's like stream delay
yeah I wish that we could see your
messages instantly in the respond to
them instantly but Oh attack on titan
crossover oh I'd be real good like a
whole other weapon set that is just the
the blades gravity is your Jeep fly
fight the swords they use are pretty
much just the dual blades
yeah so that actually would cross over
pretty well yeah yeah yeah yeah that's a
good one
that's a pretty good one also I like I
like the idea for a doom crossover I
want a great sword that is actually just
a shotgun but they're doing crossovers
like at that point like a like a convert
total conversion mod like yeah but I'm
into that I'm very into that all right
still Ryu I'm still getting over that
fact that I
one shot by a boulder see Godzilla
crossover would make a lot of sense I
would if anything because we we just
fought like a weird goopy lookin
Godzilla well we do have all those uh
I've not paid attention to any of the
limited bounties and they all ended four
hours so oh no I'm not gonna get any of
those done especially since so I have to
slay five Elder we could totally knock
that out that's easy forget about it
Doughboy says but isn't that Ryu I'm so
confused because I've never played
Monster Hunter that's that's fair it's a
very confusing thing because it is Ryu
but they do crossover stuff in Monster
Hunter so you can unlock different
outfits or different kind of character
models and you can you can play with
them so the the crossover they put out
today is the Street Fighter crossover
we're also gonna get Sakurai at a
certain point mm-hmm there's gonna be a
good time but we've also got like you
can you can get some cool emotes that
let you do like a Hadouken or like like
a sure you can and they actually do
damage when you you fight you can kind
of do cool stuff like that yeah it's a
good time
big fan also if you've never played
monster honor this is a perfect time to
jump in if it looks kind of cool yeah
yeah absolutely have we tried to
Hadouken her sure you can a monster yet
I did it earlier on the the actual
question we're fighting the bear off
I'll do it more though I mentioned it
does at least something oh yeah the the
Hadouken does like ten to eleven damage
and the sure you can look like it did
like four to six that's a viable
strategy then yeah and also you can
knock your friends back with them which
is great probably the more important
thing it's definitely the more important
thing that's a classic thing for crash
say crash bandicoot I see you crash it's
not true though I love you crash but
that's that's mean but I can tell you I
watched you post up that next quest yeah
yeah tell he doesn't mean it though cuz
you put a smiley face afterwards
which is good all right do we want to do
this one again the the two tigresses I
don't know if there's really much of a
reason to I mean we you want to see how
fast we can kill to jaggers's just to do
it cuz it'll it'll be like a like a
five-minute thing like just real quick I
mean I guess for the sake of of
completing of the events yeah sure why
not
all right I'm down no weapon with were
you I don't think so no so were you a
gun it's true actually I you know what
I'm gonna use the gun that I made the
other night do it up man because why not
because that's funny it's it's a silly
thing to see were you running around
with a gun there we go oh you guys you
guys are too quick it's not okay sure
look I need you in here I can't I can't
do this kids can't sky guys I need I
need someone to leave and you would just
cancel the whole thing and then oh I
just go to the lady and talk to her
sorry guys you're you're all very eager
and excited but I can't I can't tell me
it's okay we got it
uh money mo wants to know how much you
guys are enjoying the game all the
amount a lot a lot a lot make sure to
use your voucher that's really important
for this piston definitely cuz I want to
make sure I get all what is it like six
thousands and he had get from it alright
we made it we did it we do this one we
got plenty of people in this session
though yeah we do nice I'm gonna make
sure I eat up you know make sure I'm
real strong ready for this and I think a
couple of them so here's a question if
you don't have the Street Fighter data
but someone else post the quest that
in the sessions maybe able to join yeah
so if you're in here and you don't have
the ability to maybe get it if someone
is posting that quest you might be able
to do it that way so that's just a guess
though I'm not a hundred percent on that
one they have do wielding guns yet or do
you do a token you can do a Hadouken no
do oiled and yet though Bob and I'm glad
that you're checking in on that so we're
gonna make it happen we're gonna get
those those dual guns oh I almost
smooched gear out there before I left I
want to do that every day same big same
but yeah probably doubt two to three
shot them you know shy guy that might
actually be the case but I'll find out
it'll be a good time we'll find out
together as a group
what were you how monster hunter the
same Alex its if they did a crossbow
request I think you're I think you're
asking how it's it's a thing but it's
it's a cool cool crossover that you can
you can unlock a Ryu in all right gonna
make sure I grab these things cuz it's
gonna be very serious got some some
potions ready okay good I think they're
just gonna walk out of the same place
whoop I really like that I just have
this like big dumb old old-fashioned gun
like a flintlock kind of deal and that
you're also reading I'm also real
momoney wants to know if you guys think
this is one of the best games ever made
like some people emphasis on one of the
best or is that a stretch um no I mean
that's a definition like saying
anything's like the best game ever made
probably not no but I mean I can say I
think this is one of the best games this
year so far for sure which is also maybe
not saying heads that's fair
I don't I
I like Wow lost or dead anyway everyone
I think Harv that this is my favorite
Monster Hunter that's pretty big thing I
don't know if it's like the best game
ever but it's it's good it's very good
I can also admit that it's not a game
for everyone
absolutely see I'm going to wherever
this next Jagger's just gonna just gonna
Hadouken it yeah just to see how that
works out
porous where's the other chakras where
did they go we got some pals over here
cat pals what's up guys talk to me this
is not the right time you will know when
the time is right you can have this I
gave me a pill thank you
where is that up there boy it's probably
inside of one of the caves maybe just
run around and check out all the places
where digresses usually are I can do
that
oh I should just no that's not it that's
not what I wanted to say mention Jojo
characters I'd be very into that it's
pretty good give wants to know ya goob
now you're totally able to jump out
mid-game wit man at any point in fact
there's like a whole system called SOS
flare where you can summon people to
join your mission so why did they yeah
it's pretty easy just like swapping it
out they got rid of my emotes they
changed my customizations you know I
don't need these ammo things so I'm just
gonna I'm gonna put them back in token
over there I found him shoot one sec
I'll be there
there we go put those back there we're
good
alright oh you're you're right here
you're I thought you were gonna be
really far away um right here nice oh he
does like gotta have a Rambo thing going
on with him
he's got they're really sweet headband
good call it's true it is kind of a mean
thing to jump out of a game in this
because it does leave the monster at a
higher health oh yeah I'm not saying you
should do that but the fact that the
game doesn't like lock you in or
anything or you can't rejoin or anything
like that well I got this guy's it's a
good thing I'm here I'm gonna bring the
pain here we are
damn brought it did he did you get a
token um no no I'm gonna do it now
though oh man God look at this mean jag
hrus yeah we got it nailed it guys good
good stuff don't even I don't feel like
I need to cut this poor thing up I don't
even know join after swapping in here
I'll uh I try hard xxx
great name so does love your YouTube
videos thank you oh thank you we love
you keep keep doing you you I'm gonna
I'm gonna uppercut this uh there we go
come on
Oh it stuns okay nice I almost got it I
almost I almost defeated that monster
with my bare fists it's a time should I
put on like my actual gear for this
probably okay I'm I was down to try and
ride it out with Ryu but
I feel like I don't know I I don't want
to go through all of it and then have us
not finish it you know just as Ben was
wearing a stupid Ryu look okay I'm here
to do one thing and that's roleplay my
Street Fighter character of choice Ryan
Hakan if I could play as icon in this
game I wouldn't use any of the other
armors
because you know they give him some
weird like slide all over the place kind
of thing
Oh sliding instead of sprinting he just
slides uh I want everything to do with
that exclusively and nothing else
there's a barrel bomb he gets an oil
bomb oh and everything just gets real
slippery oh that would be good all right
so where did my Pookie go tonight oh did
I neglect him okay oh there he is found
him Keith come here he ran away doesn't
love me anymore
he hates me that's good that's real good
all right so we're gonna attempt the the
last the last event quest that they put
up for this week where we have to fight
five monsters in the ancient forests 50
minutes apparently it's not as difficult
as I'm thinking it might just be like
maybe they're not high rank maybe they
will ring maybe we're just maybe we're
just gonna be really good high rank but
there's a hiring quest ah Ruby Raygun I
shouldn't need my cat Raygun hmm they
really need to add a thing for the tail
rider safaris like out in the open some
completely stop doing them yeah having
to go back to your house to do it kind
of sucks oh good all these these cool
gears dreadful said they named their
Pookie squeezin I like it
so I went back to using my Eau de Guerre
and set I'm feeling pretty sad I I like
it a lot
because the pro you got this quest I
appreciate that you think that we're pro
try my best I try my best for you we got
some I like just looking at everyone's
armor yeah like it's cool seeing where
everyone's going with all their stuff
that's cool that's one of the sets the
the event one right oh no it's the the
collection edition so that's not
actually a set it's actually just a
transpose I can I still do the the
emotes as not real
I should be questioned that's a real
silly question
oh heck yeah I like that that's good so
I can still I can still troll my friends
with sure you right yeah it's a rank 7
so now this is definitely no joke yeah
deep green blues alright I have posted
it I'm gonna use a voucher voucher no
quest have been posted that's a lie
there we go made it I'm gonna use a
voucher too cuz I believe in us that
much game rate videos wants to know any
word about upcoming DLC monsters yeah
they're gonna add double june deviljho
at some point that angry angry pickle
dinosaur I think they just said spring
was the last we've heard so that'll be a
fun time whoa it's like a dude version
of me romance oh wait I thought that was
you anyway and I don't realize that he's
got a long sword dang that's good it's
got the same hair the same armor though
I like it it's cool cool I bet you got I
had to ditch my eye patch and I feel
about more I see monsters we're gonna
get some new ones so they haven't set
any monsters over and GG oh but you said
there have been some ice boys
there's was it like a Lego me I think is
what it was called it's like a weird rat
bear creature that slides around
everywhere if Hakan were a monster
hunter monster that's the one he would
be like that and my favorite like this
this inflatable I shark I forget his
name but he's really cool cuz he pops
out of the ground he's got ice armor and
then he like inflates himself in the
bounces around it's a real good time but
I'd like to see either of those show up
again ain't pretty good load be
interesting though because there's no
ice environment in the game we got this
mister dreadful it's happening we're
gonna do this this hunt we're gonna do
is hunt real real good real real good
time for a hunt the true path lies in
the heart of the monster you just carved
out that's the real quote we were
looking for the whole time all right all
right just put me right here oh well
dang dude well we'll be there in a sec
we'll meet up it'll be a good times
that's weird that it put me there all
right I've already found uh luckily
objective is just all monsters the Tobii
katashi
that'll be a good one to knock out also
I'm just realizing I forgot to get
potions I mean I can I should be fine if
I need to head back to a camp but yeah I
was maybe a little foolish do we have to
kill we have to kill this guy too
yeah no we'll clean up the the Jaguars
oh yeah sure that'll take you like what
a minute hopefully keep it on a high
rank it's still pretty quick yeah he's
he's a bit of a silly pushover kinda
yikes
bringing the pain I love it
he's uh he's still taking taking a few
hits oh no I missed there we go
one down cool all right we're still
still on our way to you that's fine you
holding up all right okay you're you're
fine I'm doing fine you're you're a plus
so I wanna I want to say it makes me
really proud to see how much of a
monster honor you've turned into oh
sorry I remember what I was like all the
betas coming up I wonder who's gonna be
a little plain I'm kind of interested
yeah give it a go I've always on the try
and now you're over here so low and so
low and high ranked monsters by yourself
oh well I'm a proud proud mobster hunter
oh and then dying I'm it's okay we can
overlook that that's fine sometimes you
need to fall to understand and grow as a
person it's a-okay that's my favorite
Batman quote why do we fall so we can go
back to camp and get potions because for
some reason the game decided to drop me
in the middle of a fight oh this is on
the ps4 see
Oh multiplayer buff monsters - that's
true
alright let's do this
mess him up silly electric lizard
squirrel thing I was gonna run away
don't run away I just got here
where you going the party's just
starting woof I have a piercing pot I
could have stopped it I could have
stopped it oh come on
and hey that's doing where were chasing
down your squirrel boy using you headed
to the beach I think which is kind of a
cool thing
oh no he's not headed to the beach hehe
took a left turn someone so rank we are
I believe I'm ranked 28th think I'm like
50 29 not sure I'd have to I have to
check
well yeah I'm 50 something like low 50s
oh you guys are right by me yeah
okay got my health back
who we got people on the tail again this
one's this one's in the bag oh yeah oh
yeah this guy's clothes feel bad that
I've abandoned my switch axe and gone
back to to longsword but like I was
gonna say long sword feels really good
and I feel like I'm almost unstoppable
and then of course I sidestepped and do
a like a paralysis cloud thank you and
your your your flurry of hits you you
ended up knocking me out of my yeah
really
my dizzy state yeah there we go
yeah this is why we don't put legs on
snakes that I couldn't have said it any
better myself
all right so that's two down three to go
this actually isn't too bad yeah I
missed on that Jagger's carve yeah I
yeah did you know I mean actually
actually did miss out on it but Dan says
he's 57 that's good it's a good healthy
number oh cool all material so I know we
got a fight in engine ass what are the
other ones we got a Picabo key and a
rathalos okay so pukey puke he might
actually be back this way cuz I know he
likes to hang out in this weird area so
we can try to hit him up
yeah it's typically where he is the very
least to find some tracks we could've
devil there is perfect found him and
then we might be able to hit off from
him into the engine half and then finish
with the rathalos probably yeah sounds
good yeah I hate how I feel like I like
I just I've studied this and I'm like oh
yes the the engine earth usually
frequents this area but like that's
Monster Hunter yeah
pretty quickly you're like yeah it's
it's over here usually I'm just gonna
run away here for a second and get my
poison off of me I mean he'll because I
forgot to change
these are going to quit this is all
calculated Bob every single bit of it a
hundred percent oh yeah yeah this is the
worst possible scenario Oh God
come back here stop wiggling
I can't huh you that's what real gross
sounded real that's real gross never
seen him do that I think it's a it's a
high rank you keep you key thing okay
goodbye see you later it's gonna go up
to his nest there's gonna have now not a
bad way it's like nah man that's not me
I'm not gonna do that no taint no
problem oh no man
dang goob dang tape someone he always
fixes everything here actually it's true
he's not here today so if something goes
wrong we're in for a wild ride that is
on me to figure that out I think I think
we can I think we can figure it out we
could we could make it work oh yeah yeah
don't run away please no come back come
back whoops
didn't mean to poke eeeh I thought I got
the tail there we go
came in see what's happening it's just a
mess oh now who's real dead but I feel
kind of bad I feel like we've really
that was a bad way to go
you know the pew pew he's another one
that I kind of feel bad killed they're
only like like a few a handful monsters
I feel bad oh we did cut off the tail at
one point no I don't see it on the map I
don't either and it was definitely here
a second ago
oh it's pretty underneath it Oh perfect
it's all I guess I must have
automatically carpet then yeah all right
well cool stuff maybe the engine death
is over to the right I know where it is
you already got it on lock nice we're
already on the road I mean I was jumping
all over us hitting things things things
were getting hit for sure there's so
many numbers everywhere oh my god did I
not look where I was walking I wasn't
looking where I was walking it's one sec
okay there is our Black Stars already on
it turn back of brown this way
all right whoa Black Stars uh which acts
least Joe yeah I think it's the the near
Yonsei one maybe
was there a New Yorker got a weapon for
everyone I think so because we've got
that whole the whole Newark you can
taste set going on oh yeah it does
aw stupid tail
whoof
I'm on fire
whoo wolf I'm getting hit this is
actually a lot like I don't want to jinx
it or anything but I feel like this is
easier than I thought it was gonna be I
agree
apart from that me dying thing your your
soul on a multiplayer monster you
goodness
Oh No she's eating you we spoke too soon
I'm just gonna get into this
regenerative pool somebody put you hang
out there yeah
so once know what qatada this is the one
that I'm using is the the blue rathalos
one it's like a highest tier fire damage
which means it's not gonna do much to
engine App Engine ass but it's still
still pretty beefy ouch w ch
come back here
there we go
wants to run away don't do it I was just
thinking about how we've kind of kept
him here for a while yeah get him with
those two those pests are yeah
who's gonna jump no I went back up Chirk
just doing a really good job of trying
to lose us youch well you know as as
your rathalos that's that's what we're
talking about
well okay come back here mmm you wanna
pick this up I like these a lot
I like these a lot what is it you're
shootin oh the bomb oh yeah those are
good yeah oh he's limping okay you know
I said a handful kind of make me sad
when I I'm going after him but it was
there's a little part of me whenever
they're limping away where I'm like but
also I mean it's monster honor they're
they're doing something bad they need to
be taken care of they're gonna ruin the
environment
grab that I'm not gonna grab that you
can pick up that Rathalos scale actually
it will help us zoom in on that guy
there we go I see it a party
and he's dead by party I mean die sweet
and hey look who showed up
is that the rapper that's a rathalos
perfect cutting up a tree all right I'm
gonna get their car Vicent cool yikes
dang it oh no I'm gonna - no yep okay
yes sure
all the way down yeah I'm in geez just
took me completely out of the fight oh I
keep trying to get on them come on up
and there now they're underneath it it's
the max amount of people that can kill
one monster together for but you're your
Lobby can hold up to well there we go
hold up to 16 I've got my sliding
affinity on whoo yes yes okay a little
bit a little bit
should be yeah yeah yeah there we go
down
nailed it I should on the tail but the
head was so close just go for it
don't worry we're on the tail also I
think all of us have bladed weapons
anyway tails already off perfect all
according to plan
yeah
it's gonna keep doing this as long as I
can it's a good way to do it
are you just doing your your your tail
thing yeah where I keep going bouncing
off these mushrooms
oh no don't come to me stay away from me
okay you're moving I'm gonna do this
tail carve I'm gonna bring them back
here watch I'm gonna get my tail carve
200 nope nope no no I got it sweet yeah
see everything is calculated it's all
all good yeah the part of the grand plan
yeah that looks really cool from where I
was I was very into it oh my god I'm on
fire and I'm dazed excellent presently
the other day I was fighting at a Ostra
because I'm dumb and I really wanted to
I got set on fire like oh my god akin
yes yes yes set on fire I was dazed
inside of the lava and it was just the
worst combination of everything oh my
god it was asking if there's no raid
monsters yet so great monsters would be
an interesting thing but it's not
something that Monster Hunter has ever
really done oh god I'm gonna die that's
fine we don't we're on the last monster
they're almost dead we don't need to
worry about it it's fine everything's
fine see one of these one of those he's
he's almost dead we're fine I've got a
long he's making a book in it
whoa this is a heck of a hunt yeah
I like this so these are the ones that I
was kind of like I was hoping they'd get
to really quickly so I'm happy they're
starting to show up or they're just like
hey fight all the wyverns at the same
time and you're like that sounds like a
good idea just kind of weird wacky crazy
dangerous dangerous hunts the most
dangerous game try figure this game out
little by little if you want to know
anything please feel free to ask I'm
happy doubt the more people I can trick
into trying monster hunter the better
because I just want everyone to try it
because it's a very good time are we
gonna trap him oh we are gonna trap him
yeah I'm down
you got my tranq bombs out ready is he
good if be trapped yet think so it's got
a really faint heartbeat I know where
the trap is though he's running
underneath them really
there it is go to sleep go to sleep nice
just like that perfect perfect yeah whoo
it's a Ponzi scheme I mean if if you
think it's the scheme because I want to
get more friends to play this game with
me all right Ben so that's all the event
quest for this week
yes normally we go for about two hours
we play till 1:00 we might want to go a
little less just because we're gonna be
doing Bayonetta at 2:00
yeah we're gonna be back playing us
another game and do some prep stuff for
that
so we'll probably go for another 15 so
I'd say we can think one more thing what
is jazz I didn't get any gems so many
gems oh man your turn to get all the
gems it's about time might be able to
convince a few people play this on PC
we'll see I I'm really excited to see
how how it works on the PC getting like
a constant high frame rate and you know
what I have a thing we should do well
what is that
I still haven't beaten Black Diablos yet
let's give it a try
I'm do you have the the thing for it I
do oh snap yeah I'm in sign me up so I'm
gonna head back to it the gathering hub
yeah let's do it I'm in I'm very in
I'm also very afraid but it'll it'll be
a good time oh just shake it all that
setup oh my harvest box is full and I
have bounties to complete so do all
these these checkups these turn-ins
leave all that cuz I'm still trying to
get more stuff for for capturing know
what the end game is like uh be honest
you're kind of looking at it it's just
doing doing more hunts and taking on
stuff as it it comes out as event quests
and there's some special and game-like
materials called extreme stones that you
try and farm yeah that's kind of how you
get into like your your min maxing like
how am I going to become the very best
instead of just the best okay so I have
yeah I still have the optional quest for
him ooh I'm and I do have I also have an
investigation as an optional quest yeah
get that done man okay yeah let's do it
gonna use the bow I'm not gonna go
anywhere near the thing yeah that's fair
I'm gonna be dumb and I'm gonna try to
still use my sword no I don't want to
post a quest I want to join a quest to
go back available quest optional yes
sure do it I'll check it on the squad
I'm gonna invite anyone who isn't
already in the squad sounds good to me
oh we have so news time for a hundred
and five
dang though been going in Oh
[Music]
mmm nah I'm gonna ride it out longsword
longsword til the day I die and then I'm
gonna switch my weapon because I got
carted off
[ __ ] black Diablo her power is she's
basically an elder dragon is what we're
learning yes so buckle up this is gonna
be one heck of a weights and this dream
today
yikes let's do it I'm ready
that's gotta eat ready is all as I'll
ever be
oh we got a give a paid for a meal thank
you thank you for the food the free meal
I like it that cats just so stoked about
everything she's happy to bring you your
food and just throws the throws the lid
every time all right whoo let's do it
trying to think about everything but the
fact that we're about to definitely get
on this a whole bunch see shoot rocks at
the small birds to make them scream
we'll make the devil's come up from the
ground that as true cuz the the screamer
stuff is how you kind of force it from
where it was I didn't realize you could
shoot the the birds to make them do that
oh no I didn't actually make it to a
camp why I always do that for some
people randomly high-ranked man it gets
wild things just going off all over the
place I grab some of these things though
dig through these bone piles found a
quality bone
found a lot of quality bones alright I'm
not too far from you guys which is nice
okay
oh hello there grab these do not have a
lead on it but it's typically you see
it's it's probably in its its hideout
area yeah wish everyone a quality bone
this weekend say mr. dreadful same
that's all we can really hope for all
right I'm getting cat I'm like I'm
getting kinda like like a like a little
bit of a shake going I'm like this isn't
you
uncharted territory if you fought him
yet no oh you haven't bought me it
either oh it's a small bear off here to
ruin my jump thanks see you later
is there a street fighter event so there
is a street fighter arena quest we have
a guide I think either up for it or
coming up for it on the website if you
want to find more details out but
basically you you do the hunt like seven
times and you get enough tickets to
create a set of armor that makes you
look like Ryu from Street Fighter I'm
just gonna slide down here ah yes
question mark question mark scratch is
perfect I wonder what this is I'm just
kidding we all know what it is whoa the
the pit Artem DUP is that a regular one
that's a regular Diablos I'd rather not
mess with that yeah I what research
because unlike the original when she
curves up suddenly hits jump so she
literally jumps out skidding from the
sand oh boy there's gonna be a spicy
fight
do I want to jump down there I'm gonna
do it I'm gonna do it ah boy man there's
nothing down here there's nothing down
here at all no I know I know where it is
is it in like the the absolute hiding
areas usually over here oh there it is
there it is so uh yeah any time you guys
can go uh totally let ya know yes the
perfect introduction I have attempted to
fight this once oh really and I did die
I'm counting on it I'm gonna be the guy
that ruins it for everyone I've already
been hit badly it's okay it's fine this
is this is fine
don't hit its head you dummy don't don't
do that okay it's bad start oh there's
the charge
yeah I don't like that there we go
red-eyes black dragon no I can't believe
this can feel it really okay like I'm
not know just be careful I'm just maybe
I'm just there's a charge coming yeah
Jack Rooney's shoutouts to insurance
always make sure you're insured
yikes double yikes uh yeah I want you to
get out of here I don't want to be the
next one I don't want to be the next one
no where'd it go
oh there it is yeah that uh get goes
much further than the other one that was
a good call that looked really cool I'm
gonna run away now gonna be not here
mm-hmm
bring bring them out into the open come
on come on over this way don't fight me
and your your your sand waterfall home
oh don't let her go to the open area
this is we gotta keep her in here
apparently never mind don't don't follow
us stay here
oh yeah cuz that just means they can
they can dig in and charge all over the
place I'm Stein poacher you're good get
out get out of there it's the most
accurate poke I've ever done
yeah sure okay oh shoot I'm dead I'm
dead there's good knowing you as soon as
I saw the stars above my my health meter
I was I knew I knew it was it was the
end um oh I can grab stuff from a box
now do you don't feel like we're even
close she does swing more wildly I am
definitely noticing this that's right
that just means we'll have to come back
and we'll have to get our revenge it'll
be the the epic the epic saga it's not
any of the other dragons that gives us
the biggest problem in this game is just
stupid black Diablos oh dang it I'm
jumping I'm gonna take these these
nutrients you know I'm fine I'm fine if
if we if we die on this I want to
because that means I have a monster in
this game that I have to beat still is
what I would say is rationalization for
us up she left oh I think she's down
below she's still here in fact if you
want to jump oh you know I am heck yeah
I don't know if I'm gonna be able to
land on no unfortunately not she you
could have earlier but she moved
this is the most frightening situation
kind of standing there and I'm nervous
oh now we're fighting now we're actually
fighting where did they go mm-hmm this
is what we need the screamer pods for
our they moved no well that's good
because the other Diablos was about to
come in Bob Jones sis don't forget about
bayonetta stream guys yeah don't worry
we lose this fight we're gonna be
quittin in around a few minutes here
yeah unless Bob Jones is reminding
everyone else about the banister in
which case thank you yeah that's sweet
sweet promo tune in for more video game
adventure ah it'll be a good time this
is very precarious to you because we
lost a lot of lives and like a good 30
seconds it was real quick grab these
footprints oh I shouldn't have done that
I thought that was a footprint but it's
not and it's clearly not why would I do
that
oh okay well laying on oh I hit him I
saw you try was it wasn't enough yeah no
nope that also wasn't enough dang it
there we go mounted someone someone gone
we're good
awesome and then it just kind of ran
yikes
oh hello yes hi Oh God come for the tail
you know what it's not exactly how I
wanted that to go but I'm happy that it
happens
mmm
oh no the Bharath has left shoot what
are we gonna do I want to put this here
oh oh he found you guys I'm hopping down
Geralt was so like he wants it up
there's gonna be any Bayonetta cosplay
in this dream stay tuned to find out I
was really looking for an excuse to use
my they excuse me beware what where'd
they go
I just watched them dig into that new
mop yeah never mind it's probably better
I don't think about it alright they're
back
are they are they hurting I I can't
actually see what I think so I don't
believe they are
oh there they are Oh found him coming in
with the charge no no get out of here
don't do this to me No
all right this is a perfect opportunity
to shoot some of those uh those
pterodactyl dudes
I shouldn't have reached that but I did
oh the stupid I hate how the working
like knock you out of an attack midair
so there's there's actually like a stat
that prevents that it's just like
logically this makes no sense
oh look it's our boy Bagle goose is back
and there we go it's okay
that is about exactly how I would yeah
it would go that's it's understandable
we're good I think we have to end our
first monster hunter string him on it on
a on a bad now you know I don't think it
was because we learned something we did
black Diablos don't mess around with
them yeah I think we have a challenge
for next week though yes well we'll get
suited up we'll get we'll get it all
going and we'll make our run back we'll
get the salty runback I'll do it on this
this angry creature yeah so thanks guys
for joining us for this week's Monster
Hunter fridays with you the community
thanks again for everyone who popped in
filling out that session always a good
time yeah yeah we appreciate all of you
helping out and yeah stick around
because in about an hour and a half
we're gonna be back streaming some
bayonetta and Bayonetta 2 on the switch
so check that out thanks for watching
guys
you